no that's my solution for global warming
everybody's talking about cars and oil
that doesn't matter it's just too many
people you know
there's too many people doing it she
said you know you want to help the
environment just stop [ __ ]
right i'm not saying stop [ __ ] but
you know pull out
you can still have your fun right
you got to stop looking at babies like
they're these cute things all right
they're not
they're all right they are cute but most
of them are just going to grow up
there's going to end up being another
[ __ ] and like an suv that doesn't
pull out far enough into the
intersection right now you got to wait a
whole nother light to make a left and
you're just sitting there losing your
[ __ ] screaming at your windshield with
this dude who didn't need to exist
it's like there's no reason for that guy
we got that guy
[Applause]
i don't know
that's my plan they should just make
babies illegal for like the next like 25
30 years right
that'd be great
think about somebody's born three people
born every second to one person dying
right so if you're not making anybody
he's like bam somebody just died right
somebody just fell down some stairs
somebody just tripped over a skateboard
right and you know what [ __ ] lanes
just opening up on the highway right
you know you get to work a little sooner
you're in a better mood
dude you get it down to like 30 000
people
30 000 people be the [ __ ]
all right super bowl comes around
everybody can go
right
[Applause]
everybody can go 22 you get to play the
odds of you making it in the nfl it's
ridiculous
dude even if you suck you could still
you could block on punts
you'd be like a wedge breaker or maybe
that guy holding the first down mercury
yeah
you wouldn't have to recycle
there was 30 000 people man everybody
here you could literally drive your own
tank you drive a tank you could throw
toxic waste off the top
you could shoot a bald eagle right in
the head
plenty of them
plenty of them dude they're [ __ ] all
over my tank what the [ __ ] am i supposed
to do
i have a solution for global warming i
don't know if you guys are gonna like it
but this is my proposal so there's a
billion muslims and when they pray five
times a day on the last prey they should
all have to blow on the earth to cool it
down a bit
like your grandmother would do on a
spoon
i
knew it
you guys are thinking the spicy curry
breath is going to make it hotter that's
why
that's what you guys are thinking all
right well
option two the jews that control the
weather just turn it down a bit that's
just
and whatever sultan
see i'm not one of these people who's
worried about everything you got these
people around you country's full of now
people walking around all day long all
day long
worried about everything
what about the air what about the water
what about the soil
worried about pesticides insecticides
food additives carcinogens worried about
radon gas worried about asbestos
word about saving
endangered species
let me tell you about endangered species
all right
saving endangered species is just one
more arrogant attempt by humans to
control nature it is arrogant meddling
is what got us in trouble in the first
place doesn't anybody understand that
interfering with nature over 90 percent
way over 90 of all the species that have
ever lived on this planet ever lived are
gone
they're extinct
we didn't kill them all
they just disappeared
that's what nature does they disappear
these days at the rate of 25 a day
regardless of our behavior i mean
irrespective of how we act on this
planet
25 species that were here today will be
gone tomorrow
let them go gracefully
leave nature alone haven't we done
enough
we're so self-important so
self-important everybody's going to save
something now or save the trees save the
bees save the whales save those snails
and the greatest arrogance of all save
the planet
what are these [ __ ] people kidding me
save the planet we don't know how to
take care of ourselves yet we haven't
learned how to help one another we're
gonna save the [ __ ] planet
i am getting tired of that [ __ ] i'm
tired of [ __ ] earth day i'm tired of
these [ __ ] self-righteous
environmentalists
i'm tired of these white
liberal
bourgeois liberal white people who think
the only thing wrong with this planet is
there aren't enough bicycle paths
trying to make the world safe and clean
for their volvos and i'm really sick
really sick of these rock stars and
movie stars going to work off their
cocaine guilt by saving a forest
somewhere besides
besides
there's nothing besides the first of all
the environmentalists don't give a [ __ ]
about the planet they don't care about
the planet not in the abstract they
don't know what they're interested in a
clean place to live
their own habitat they're worried that
someday in the future they might be
personally inconvenienced narrow
unenlightened self-interest doesn't
impress me besides there's nothing wrong
with the planet the planet is fine
the people are [ __ ]
the people are [ __ ]
compared to the people the planet is
doing great the planet has been here for
four and a half billion years all right
four and a half billion we've been here
100 000 maybe 200 000 maybe and we've
only been engaged in heavy industry for
a little over 200 years 200 years versus
four and a half billion and we have to
conceit to think that somehow we're a
threat but somehow we're going to put in
jeopardy this beautiful little blue
green ball it's just a floating around
the sun planet has been through a lot
worse than us for a long time been
through earthquakes volcanoes plate
tectonics continental drifts solar
flares sunspots magnetic storms the
magnetic reversal of the poles
bombardments for hundreds of thousands
of years by comets and asteroids and
meteors sandstorms erosion of all kinds
cosmic radiation worldwide fires
worldwide floods recurring ice ages and
we think
we think some aluminum cans
[Music]
and some plastic bags
are going to make a difference
planet isn't going anywhere
we are
[Applause]
we're going away
we're going away
pack your [ __ ] folks we're going away
and we won't leave much of a trace
either thank god for that
maybe a little styrofoam maybe a little
styrofoam
plant will be here and we'll be long
gone just another failed mutation just
another closed end biological mistake
and then an
an evolutionary cul-de-sac planet will
shake us off like a bad case of fleas
a surface nuisance
you want to know how the planet's doing
ask those people in pompeii who are
frozen into position from volcanic ash
how the planet's doing
well if the planet's all right as the
people in mexico city or armenia or 100
other places buried under thousands of
tons of earthquake rubble if they feel
like a real threat to the planet this
week how about the people in kilauea
hawaii who build their homes right next
to an active volcano and then wonder why
they have lava in the living room
planet is going to be here a long long
long time after we're gone and it will
heal itself it will cleanse itself
because that's what it does it's a
self-correcting system the air and the
water will recover the earth will be
renewed and say if it's true that
plastic doesn't degrade well the planet
will simply incorporate plastic into a
new paradigm the earth plus plastic
the planet doesn't share our prejudice
towards plastic plastic came out of the
earth the earth probably sees plastic as
just another one of its children
could be the only reason the earth
allowed us to be spawned from it in the
first place it wanted plastic for itself
didn't know how to make it needed us
could be the answer to our age-old
philosophical question why are we here
plastic
[ __ ]
so
so
the plastic is here our job is done we
can be phased out now and i think that's
really started already don't you i mean
to be fair the planet probably sees us
as a mild threat something to be dealt
with and i'm sure the planet will defend
itself in in the manner of a large
organism like a beehive or an ant colony
can muster a defense i'm sure the planet
will think of something what would you
do if you were the planet trying to
defend against this pesky troublesome
species let's see what my
viruses viruses might be good they seem
vulnerable to viruses and viruses are
tricky always mutating and forming new
strains whenever a vaccine is developed
perhaps this first virus could be one
that that compromises the immune system
of these creatures perhaps a human
immunodeficiency virus making them
vulnerable to all sorts of other
diseases and infections that might come
along and maybe it could be spread
sexually making them a little reluctant
to engage in the act of reproduction
well that's a poetic note and it's a
start and i can dream can i
i don't worry about the little things
bees trees whales snails i think we're
part of a greater wisdom than we will
ever understand a higher order call it
what you want you know what i call it
the big electron
the big electron whoa
whoa
it doesn't punish it doesn't reward it
doesn't even judge it just is
and so are we
for a little while
thanks for being here with me for a
little while tonight
thank you
[Music]
you